después que comenzaron los ataques con
drones shahit en octubre del año pasado
nuestro comandante decidió crear estas
unidades militares móviles con
ametralladoras para proteger nuestro
cielo y nuestra capital de La amenaza de
estos drones
trabajamos en cooperación con la defensa
aérea disparamos con ametralladora y
hemos aprendido a calcular la
trayectoria del dron su velocidad el
ángulo que debemos utilizar para
disparar Y cómo hacer la observación
técnica que permite identificarlos
Aunque la mayoría de estos drones vienen
siguiendo el cauce del río nieper que
está a mis espaldas estamos en una de
las colinas que bordean el río detrás de
estos árboles se encuentra este cauce y
una de sus misiones es estar en estos
lugares elevados observando oyendo Pero
esto se hace bastante difícil en una
ciudad como kiev donde hay tanto tráfico
y tanto ruido
nuestro trabajo están ubicarnos entre
las líneas de defensas antiaéreas si la
defensa no logra disparar o solo Daniel
levemente el dron o el misil nosotros
finalizamos la labor
en las unidades nos dividimos la ciudad
y compartimos la información sobre la
dirección y el número de drones que
vienen en camino Cada unidad dispara y
si no lo logra le pasa el objetivo a la
siguiente unidad
si usáramos un arma más potente que la
ametralladora dentro de la ciudad
podríamos alcanzar una edificación y
herir a personas hay que entender que
para cada tarea hay un arma
la labor de unidades como esta se ha
mostrado esencial nuevamente en los
últimos días y semanas cuando Rusia ha
vuelto a lanzar ataques sistemáticos
contra la ciudad de kiev al principio
usaban estos drones porque buscaban
destruir infraestructura estratégica
como las plantas eléctricas luego
empezaron a usarlos para detectar la
ubicación de nuestra defensa aérea y
ahora tengo el sentimiento de que solo
los usan para asustar y atacar
infraestructura civil